[Music]
hello welcome everyone I'm Denny and I'm
with nyle hey hey
great job job thank you really skilled
at ASL you'll be really skilled in no
time thank you no I practiced I
practiced a lot you guys that's as much
a s l's I learned today for nyle but I'm
excited I got to do that
he's interpreters off to the camera but
now DiMarco you guys know who this guy
is we'll be chatting with him for the
next 20 minutes or so
taking your fan questions so type them
in the comment section below and we'll
get them to the iPad but as you can tell
I got a lot to cover with now so I'll
start first of all okay okay you don't
ask me any hard questions you know what
that's page three we got some hard
questions right here on page three okay
I mean ever since winning America's Next
Top Model and Dancing with the Stars I
mean your resume has just been growing
and growing and growing and now you're a
Broadway producer I mean how does that
feel well you know I really feel blessed
every single day you know sometimes it's
really easy to forget all the individual
successes of the last few years but
sometimes I have to slow down and just
think wow I'm here you know all those
experiences I could never even imagine
that I would even reach that point and
before all of that I was just thinking
about being a math teacher and so you
know I have a math degree and you know
from from then to now I'm really happy
that just proved there's there's just
proves there's nothing you can't do you
know you can do anything oh yeah yeah
that's right I mean how's this you know
you can do anything
absolutely how does it feel to not only
be producing a Broadway play but to be
bringing such an important story to
theater audiences well I think it's
really important because I'm really glad
I could really take up that producer
role because I really believe in
representation true representations to
happen both behind the camera or on
stage and you know my whole life is
based on my life experience as a deaf
person I really have a really great
wellspring of experience that I can
bring to the table so you know when here
people watch this play they can see the
real deaf experience and so that's the
whole point you guys have been in early
previews how's it feel or you know
what's the reaction bin has it been for
you to watch audiences walk away from
this feeling so touched you know really
I think they're obviously they really
love it because you know they've never
really seen a deaf show like that
because it's not that common that that
that would happen and so the story
itself applying to deaf people only but
it applies generally more to you know
the current political climate mm-hmm
and the play is about you know start
listening you know and often a lot of
people are not listening they're not
listening to our stories or deaf
people's stories um you know or
marginalize people in general their
voices aren't being heard so you know
they should really watch that play and
see that yeah it really applies to
everyone and everything it's about
opening up your heart you know right and
knowing that people in the deaf
community are no different everyone
wants to be loved right it's just a
little harder yeah yeah definitely um I
always say that you know there's no one
right way to be a human mm-hmm
you know we're all so diverse and the
diversity itself is beautiful and we
really have to start listening to other
perspectives and their needs um you know
and so then we can truly become one
speaking of diverse this caste is so
diverse - you have Lauren rid laughs and
of course Joshua Jackson I mean what's
been like for you to see them bring this
plate of life well really both of them
are amazing yeah Lauren and Josh and
Joshua both really I feel that they're
all the perfect match for that stage and
both the actors are just incredible
joshua has learned a lot he's really
learned a lot of signing and I mean a
lot and you know often hearing people
they can't really pick up or acquire a
lot of signs and memorize like a whole
script so a lot you know it's really
amazing to watch them both together I
mean obviously Joshua Jackson's a huge
TV star and film - I have to ask you
were you big Dawson's Creek fan um yeah
I watched it growing up yeah you know I
don't think I saw all of them but yeah I
definitely watched it every chain
they could yeah I'd have a fanboy moment
if I was working with Josh Jackson cuz
everyone knows Dawson's Creek you know
um yeah marlee matlin she came and saw
the opening preview right and of course
she won her Oscar for the film version
of this play
I mean how nerve-wracking was that to
have her in the audience I was nervous
because you know of course she won an
award obviously and she knows the story
the best and so I hoped I was really
hoping to get her approval and she
really liked it you know she was sitting
right behind me so she would kind of tap
me on the shoulder every good scene
she'd give me a little approving tap and
so you know I so okay I got her approval
that's great that's fantastic I love
that so much and so yeah it was really
good to have her come an opening night
official opening night on Broadway is
next week right
yes it's April 11th it's opening night
so we really encourage everybody to come
and watch it it's really gonna be good
you told me you're nervous yeah oh yeah
I'm nervous I don't blame you and also
you know I'd really love to tell you
this part after opening night we had a
big party you know to celebrate after
opening night and my deaf twin brother
he was deejaying that night and so all
of us you know I'm really excited to
bring in all of the deaf talent and play
so fun family and community affair right
everyone yeah if you guys are just
joining us I'm sitting down live with
nyle DiMarco we're taking your fan
questions so leave them in the comments
section and later in the show we're
gonna learn some ASL so stick around
guys it's gonna be a lot of fun you
talked about representation obviously
you're doing that behind and in front of
the camera you just had a role on that
show this close I mean what was that
experience like for you when I got on
the set um the whole experience felt
like a utopia in a way it was just like
a perfect world for me I just came in I
saw deaf people working with hearing
people together and hearing people were
learning sign too everybody was together
and really you know I really believe
that that may have been the first time
in Hollywood history that we have to
that both sides the Deaf producers and
deaf actors I don't think that's
happened before and so maybe that's
starting something new and it could be
like a new movement
and I watched all six episodes and Wow
you know they really really get into the
deaf experience and I've seen many other
shows that include you know a deaf story
but they're not but not really because
often the actors themselves aren't even
deaf yeah and the writers don't
understand Deaf culture they don't have
that personal experience so it's hard to
write an authentic story and so that
show is just amazing I can only imagine
me it's true representation matters and
there's historically speaking has been a
lack of deaf storytelling and deaf
storylines and a lot of projects so I
met I bet that was really emotional for
you to be a part of it to not just to
see oh yeah definitely it was definitely
emotional because you know I've waited
28 years for that 28 years you know it's
that's a long time mm-hmm and so I'm
really glad it's happening now better
now than ever
Oh amen to that absolutely how do you
see more acting for yourself in the
future I do want to go more acting
projects yeah definitely
um I've met with so many directors
writers producers the whole gamut and
I've been meet in meetings with them and
often they're saying oh yeah I really
love you I want to include you in our TV
shows movies or whatever but they always
ask me that question they say but how
can I write in a deaf person's
first-person perspective and I realize
that it's not really their fault because
they don't really know deaf culture and
that's what I'm here for right and so I
decided to write my own show and so I'm
getting all the ideas together because
you know my whole experience I can
really bring that to the table in
Hollywood so I'm working on a few TV
projects on my own right now and
hopefully it'll come to fruition will
happen you'll get to watch it and come
back into yeah you'll come back here to
talk about it too because that's a huge
deal I love that uh what you know for
the few shows out there that are
showcasing ASL who's doing it right I
one more time oh yes again for all the
projects out there that do feature or
showcase ASL or deaf characters who do
you feel is doing it right you know
which which shows do you admire for what
they're doing for the community which TV
shows are right now yeah like this close
maybe right yeah I think this close you
know switched at birth
switched at birth that's been going on
for five years and I've seen they really
show ASL and the best way they can on
what other shows um I think that might
be I don't know right well speaking of
switched at birth you know the actor on
that show Daniel Duran he recently took
to social media I know you retweeted it
where he was basically calling for movie
theaters to have closed captioning I was
very moved by it I know you tweeted it
out I wanted to know from you what
typically has been your movie theater
and going experience it's really funny
because growing up you know they had
closed caption on the screen and but it
was just unlimited dates and times but
now they have this device that doesn't
work at all and you know the funny thing
is is this device it costs a lot more
than just having it on screen we're
having open closed caption on screen so
you know why did they change that system
you know they should have tried to make
they've actually made things worse for
deaf people and you know and I've been
saying that you know people are willing
to share you know if you're using closed
captioning and maybe there's over a
hundred thousand people who could
retweet that and many of them have said
that they're not deaf they're hearing
but they really use closed captioning
all the time so I thought that that was
interesting it's becoming more Universal
in a way it's amazing but watching
Daniels post it was very heartbreaking
because going to the movies is one of my
favorite things to do and I think we
take for granted the fact that we can
hear it and that people are experiencing
it differently you know people who are
hearing-impaired people who are disabled
I mean it really moved me so I hopefully
that changes soon yep really um you know
since then I think about more than five
years I haven't been to a movie theater
because for that reason and so like
Daniel said you know black panther you
know I had to watch it mm-hmm
because you know I had to be there I had
to watch it and so I decided to go and
try and just be patient with that device
but about 10 minutes in I couldn't and
so you know it is heartbreaking it's
hard you
I was really pissed off actually well
it's people like you and people like
Daniel who are making a difference by
being so vocal about understand you know
or at least giving people a platform
about it so they know that's happening
and so that we can actually make some
change you know you're being you've
always been an advocate for our language
resources for the deaf community so it's
it's a step right yeah absolutely yeah
and you're completely right and I think
fortunately you know Daniel and I have a
platform and so we can really spread the
word to make change absolutely um I want
to talk to you about a young deaf
actress Millicent Simmons she was just
cast in the new John Krasinski film a
quiet place I mean how did that feel for
you like to know not only was she cast
but you know that she is now a young
rising star with a bright bright future
ahead I was really excited for her you
know her acting she's so amazing and
she's just a really bright girl too and
at just I'm very fortunate to be able to
call her my friend we keep in touch I
give her advice from time to time
and so as she's really great person and
I look forward to seeing what's ahead
for her hey you know she has a really
really bright future have you seen the
movie yet a quiet please please no I
haven't seen it yet but I will I will
soon I hear it's scary do you like scary
movies yeah well I'll have to watch to
find out right well you know you were
once a young star on the rise - I want
to take it back - America's Next Top
Model are you watching the current cycle
no no not really got much right you know
I I don't typically watch a lot of TV so
I try my best you're all so busy yeah
but I hear it's going well I think they
just finished their season right next
week is the season finale there's four
four models left yeah yeah I know
well what advice do you have for them
life after Top Model even if they don't
win I have to say you know winning
doesn't matter I think winning is not
important it's about how you hustle it's
about how you continue meeting people
and networking and you know with your
use your charm and just that winning
doesn't really mean anything
build a brand it starts there and make
it into something major yeah yeah right
and really after America's top model
that's just the beginning that's not the
end
so you know there's a lot more work to
do after America's Top Model and I
thought when I won oh you know okay I'm
all good but no it's just the beginning
I had a lot more work I believe that I
believe that you know Tyra Banks
recently revealed that she was actually
giving herself IVF treatments and shots
during your cycle like in the season
finale were you aware that that was
going on behind the scenes with her no I
was not aware of that about that IVF but
that's funny because you know during the
show I heard a little rumor that it was
possible she was possibly pregnant but
you know that's it I wasn't completely
aware but if she's if she's continuing
to do that that's great well she does
have a beautiful baby boy now chorus so
yeah I do you guys keep in touch you and
Tyra
oh yeah we're still in touch yeah you
know she's my dear dear friend and a
good mentor yeah absolutely she gave me
a lot of such great advice if I ever
need help I always reach out to her
she's someone as you mentioned who has
been so successful but the hustle
doesn't stop I mean she's still doing
everything she can right yeah she's
right that's right yeah I mean it's Tyra
Banks she's still continuing to hustle
oh it's everybody she's been around for
a long time and she's still pounding
pavement
oh yeah and she does everything to talk
shows movies TV whatever it's crazy I
think that's a secret to longevity so
take notes folks everybody take notes on
that all right we have some love coming
from you from Sarah from Facebook she
said she says love everything you have
done to advocate for your community
community many of your posts have opened
my eyes how does it feel hearing that
let me hear some we see it again here
how do I feel about that I feel really
honored to have that platform and
honestly it's it's a little bit of a
burden it's a big responsibility to hold
that platform you know and and I try and
have a high standard and represent all
different kinds of deaf people and I
always feel that you know I can take
that responsibility I'm willing to take
it and I've received a lot of support
from the deaf community and I feel that
you know it's it's like validation that
I'm doing the right thing when I hear
that kind of feedback so I'm really
honored absolutely
Emily from facebook says you've opened a
lot of doors and brought awareness with
winning on Top Model and Dancing with
the Stars what doors are you hoping
children of a lesser God will open
great question Thank You Emily I think
I'm hoping that new doors could possibly
be open for more more deaf plays more
deaf producers deaf writers and so just
to empower our community to really
create our own concept and so I'm really
hoping for that I love that fans are
asking if we could bring in the
interpreter for deaf fans to see what
I'm saying come on in all right
this is Justin folks Justin here is
gonna be joining us so you guys could
see what we're all saying good good
timing because we've still got half an
interview left sorry now it wasn't my
foot they forced me to come we need a
right welcome to my world I'm happy to
have you well thanks for joining us
Justin okay so obviously Dancing with
the Stars the all athletes season is
coming up very very soon as a mirror
ball winner yourself what are three tips
you have for these people who are about
to compete on the show oh I have so many
I have so many but what's funny is when
I first got on Dancing with the Stars
they said that you'll have time for
yourself you can do other word no mm-hmm
you know you're gonna be busy just
focusing on self-care drinking a lot of
water rehearsing yes and eating a lot
more because you're gonna lose a lot of
weight you know I lost a lot of weight
before and after I lost so much weight
because you know it's four months of
continuous ongoing you know no weekends
off practice is seven days a week so
it's really crazy and finally you know
just have fun yeah you know it's a great
opportunity to get to know other people
too so use that opportunity wisely and
have a lot of fun you know it's so funny
you say fun because this see
of course is all athletes you had a
couple of athletes on your season
they're good like they're really good
and we recently talked to Artem Allen
and Gleb and they told us this season's
gonna be the most intense ever I mean
what do you think it's gonna be like
when all those athletes are competing
against each other well I'm really
hoping there's there's no [ __ ] fits or
anything or anything like that but I
think it'll be well mostly chill intense
but chill because you know during my
time I was with Antonio Brown and Von
Miller and you know they were great
athletes for NFL teams and they were
really chill okay you know so I think
probably it'll be chill but I bet maybe
if Adam rippen if he's on it it's gonna
be intense
lissa you know he's gonna tear them up
et has learned a damn rip on will be
there Tonya Harding and Janie Anderson
and you know obviously Jamie and Adam
just competed in the Olympics so it
might happen
those [ __ ] Fitz might have it well
there's gonna be some fights that are
gonna happen then well let me ask you
were there any [ __ ] fits on your season
yeah did I experience a [ __ ] fit well
not you personally or maybe someone else
who's competing I think maybe I've seen
in some case you know people who are
very exhausted yeah and so maybe it's
basically like running all day dancing
is like running and so you're really you
know I don't think they were prepared
for it in a way so your mind can
breakdown in some ways you're right it's
an also a very high-stress situation in
such a short amount of time right so
everyone's kind of sprung that's right
in the beginning you know you learn
about one dance a week and then later on
you had two dances three dances know and
you know the highest I I didn't know I
wasn't sure if I could do it but I
continued yeah it was really crazy you
won you went all the way well you fit
all the way you're like thank goodness
like - right yeah that was important it
was important that I did it and then
winning okay
what do you keep your mirror ball um
it's just sitting at home in my
apartment you know collecting dust now
has a little ring of dust on top of it
I look do you um still keep in touch
with pita and Max I know you guys are
we're very very close oh yeah
you know they're really busy too but we
keep in touch from time to time and so
they're doing their tour now they're on
tour right now right and of course they
have baby shine now what's it been like
to see your old partner pita and Max be
parents you know you knew them before
the baby shy was around yeah I know
that's right it is crazy and it's funny
because I was the one who found out that
pita was pregnant during my show and so
you know I said are you pregnant and she
said how do you know you're not supposed
to announce that nice don't tell anyone
and you know it's supposed to be two
months she's still at about two months
and so I was like okay fine but the only
reason why I caught it is because I felt
that she was hiding something from me
mm-hmm like you know she had to run to
the bathroom real quick maybe to throw
up I'm sure or something like that and
then to come back and you know saying I
don't feel good and I said you know I
think if we're we want to win this we
have to be a hundred percent honest with
each other and so you know it was a good
memory oh you called her out you got it
out of her you had to and during the
last dance before we want everything I
told pita you know let's dance for three
me you and your unborn baby so and then
we want it see that's how you won you
know you it was the baby you dance for
three yeah that's right I love that Tori
from you - I was really good question
would you ever do an all-star season of
Dancing with the Stars like if you had a
chance to go back and compete again
would you do it sure yeah yeah I really
enjoyed the experience at Dancing with
the Stars experience there was so many
people so many dancers the crew was
great too
and I'd really to go back and challenge
myself one more time I'd like to see you
compete against Adam rip on I mean did
you watch him in the Olympics oh yeah I
was watching I liked religiously
watching yeah right I love Adam I love
it you guys would be really good I can
see you guys compete against
each other yeah all right I think it's
time to learn some sign language what'd
you think
all right so I want your help can you
teach me a couple of millennial or
internet slang some some phrases okay
here we go
how do I sign woke woke woke oh that's
easy what woke you know you're woke how
about sorry not sorry sorry not sorry
sorry not sight you hear that sorry not
sorry
sorry not and you gonna do with the face
right oh yeah facial expressions are so
important yes culture facial expression
well I got plenty of those Niall
I got plenty of facial expressions hum
gasps Queen gasps yes Queen Oh Queen
Queen Queen Oh Queen like a sash okay
spilling the tea you know spreading the
gossip talking about it spilling the tea
okay just like this gossip spreading
gossip oh I'm really good at that in
more ways than one let me tell ya
spilling the tea I like that um how
about BAE BAE BAE that's a good one all
right babe I like that Niall is BAE oh
yeah oh you're a BAE thank you
goals af you know goals AF goal goals
goals those a F as [ __ ] ah okay one more
time goal goals hey Jose yeah I like
that uh Netflix and chill we don't have
a sign for Netflix but you could spell
Netflix and chill like this chill wait T
it's hard to tell Ari it's hard I'll
watch you and ETF ILX in chill okay
all right you have anyone in your life
you're calling BAE that you
listen chill with these days no no one
in my life right now you're busy you're
so busy so busy I know and you know I
don't mind I'm ready but you know I want
to just foster my career first : later
on no career first people later you know
how about you got a couple more the
struggle is real struggle is real you
they struggle like this struggle is real
real struggle is real that's how I feel
on Mondays the struggle is real right
and then and then I say this I can't
even how do i how do I sign I can't even
I can't even I can't even I can't I
can't even I like this okay I can't
thank you now I know now I know yep
you're an expert yourself hey thank you
luan congratulation thank you I give you
my Dancing with the Stars award here you
go I'll take it
I will take it gladly before we go I
just want to let you know there's so
much love coming in for you fans are so
grateful that you're here chatting with
us so and I am too so thank you and
before we go we got to show a tweet that
you just tweeted yesterday it's a little
throwback of you in high school
and you now and you say if you don't
love me at my that you don't deserve me
at my this I mean first of all I think
you look handsome them both I really do
but what uh what advice do you have for
that young Niall the one there on that
left photo that you know now what would
you tell him if you could well I think I
would say to my young self the Stars
will align for you don't worry just keep
going and and do whatever and you know
and honestly I don't think I would
change anything to be honest
you shouldn't it clearly led you right
down to the right path right yeah it's
just perfect I love that well listen now
you really are an inspiration and and
not just for the deaf community for
everybody and like you mentioned there's
a lot of minorities
in the world right now who need to be
watching shows like children of a lesser
God and hearing your story and so thank
you for giving so many people a platform
and thank you for hanging out with me
today thank you thank you and thank you
for having me of course I had a lot of
fun a blast
thank you to our fans too right yes
thank you guys thank you for watching
hope you learned some sign language of
course you guys we will be back tomorrow
with a new daily Denny and special
surprise we're actually gonna be live
every Thursday at 12 o'clock here on
YouTube e t--'s YouTube channel and
Facebook so stick around you guys thanks
so much for watching and of course we'll
have more on Dancing with the Stars over
at ET online.com and all that casting
scoop we dug it up for you guys so enjoy
and enjoy your week goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]